this podcast is brought to you by
betterhelp online therapy my friends get
unstuck with better help learn more and
save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's betterhelp
help help.com genius
your nose is so big it looks like you
can smell trouble with that thing oh
right oh
all I said oh and I was like Singa all
right
suddenly I go back to a page I'm blocked
and I'm like what why why am I blocked
how many likes did this comment get well
this is what happened so we have
reconciled since and she apologized to
me she said she just was a little
sensitive about it because in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast hey everybody yeah I'm
like you shut the [ __ ] up so I can
introduce you you don't introduce
yourself introduce yourself we're gonna
have to redo that whole thing all right
in five okay you know what you [ __ ]
ruin everything here we go we have Jason
Channing I was just excited to be on
your podcast yeah I could tell you
[ __ ] blew your load before anything
happened I'm sorry I I blew my lower
redo the introduction but like how you
would do it okay okay you do it okay
yeah how would you do it in six five and
four okay hold on let me do my thing I
want to introduce you I I just like that
you had to add one number to it 7 seven
six oh my God all right four one welcome
everybody for the another episode of The
Genius rating podcast we have your
amazing host Jimmy Macho owner David so
the girl goes wow I've never had
suicidal ideations
ideations bro this guy goes to therapy
that's right baby let's go
now we have [ __ ] Nick The Ear The
just kidding news cast member officially
brought into the group of JK news dude
let's go just because it's just because
they didn't have anybody else just
hey just like why I'm here today because
Pat couldn't make it dude how can I make
it we love you we love Pat We how about
we just do all four of us one day we
would but then if when we do it here I
don't know editing four audios is a
[ __ ] oh is it we gotta do that at the
studio for the for the four people one
that's a robin dude we're gonna kick it
with Robin That's Robin with the fat ass
you guys know who she is dude you look
like a letter P oh [ __ ] what do you it
up to you you [ __ ] idiot he's talking
to you you mirror him him first you next
dummy okay there's a lot of hostility
right now and a lot of touching I'm a
little bit sensory overload right now
because I was really excited but
um uh I just been
I've I've been
um you take longer I'm doing stuff for
real talk you're not being interrogated
I've been doing stand-up comedy
and uh I've been been with my wife and
um
mostly
[Laughter]
I didn't prepare any material I thought
you was gonna say some stuff and and
Nick say some stuff and nicely dude it's
a simple question of like what's up with
you you know what I dislike about you
the [ __ ] most dude let me tell you
what I just like you got to start with
this like when he's on this podcast
right or whenever he comes on JK news he
just sounds like the sweetest guy ever
if I showed you the messages that this
man sends me it is so offensive dude
every now and then I'll just get a
random message he goes hey what are you
doing David you want to get something to
eat and have your fourth dinner of the
night
what
[Applause]
people why are you fat shaming bro I'm
not fashionable as some people like to
have small meals and increments no no no
no because hey we should get dinner
sometime if you're done with your 17th
meal of the day and I'm like oh like a
body butter
like it's depending on what you mean I'm
reading my Bible you know I'm over here
speaking and talking to my Bible I'm
just like dude what the [ __ ] man you've
been you've been skinny though man no
shut up you're running a lot David's
skinny yeah man sometimes I can't
recognize you on Instagram like when you
post a story I'm like who the [ __ ] is
this dude but you slip back though do
you slip back like all the time bro hey
this guy see this the way he says things
offends me all the time that's very
[ __ ] up I didn't like how you said it
no slip like like you slip at but you
still kept it in check and it takes
discipline look at my finger right now
listen it takes discipline and you're
doing it listen I don't ever want to
hear this [ __ ] for me all right all
right when I first met you I witnessed
you get a [ __ ] Asian hate beat down
what's the problem
when we saw that I felt viscerally mad
like I was like upset like we were both
fuming I'm sorry man we were fuming in
the back I did my best you did do your
best you have you have no Hate in Your
Heart that's your problem like even
after that whole debacle even after
everything else you still say nice
things okay yeah yeah two things can I
tell you something okay two things why
there is no hate there is sadness okay
but there's no hate okay but there's two
things one thing is because
um I met you there
and number two is um it made me I
started talking to my therapist it made
me know that uh because I was like I
always questioned I was like man am I a
[ __ ]
yes or not you didn't need therapy for
that you could have literally just
called me one day and be like am I a
[ __ ] I've been like yes yes a fire
therapist that I would hung up on your
ass
I'm your therapist yeah he or she
doesn't know [ __ ] this is why I need a
therapist because of guys like these
yeah
not a bully continue yeah okay so you're
the biggest bully no okay and now you're
calling me fat again continue again dude
David is a life coach but only with like
negative reinforcement that's not true
you [ __ ] idiot make something of
yourself
[Laughter]
we're at the gym I kid you [ __ ] not
one day I just woke up in the middle of
the night and I was like where would
Nick be if he never bet me that's very
true I'd still be true what do you mean
you'd be training when I first met this
guy dude
this guy you know like when you say the
phrase like piss or get off the [ __ ]
pot this [ __ ] I swear to God is
a man of zero action so much ability to
do things and he would just sit there
just contemplate like he's [ __ ]
Socrates like you stupid [ __ ] go do
something about it oh it hurts because
it's so true here they are I talked to
my therapist about it because of David I
talked to my therapist about David too
how he [ __ ] dude he shines a light on
me bro can't you say this first
congratulations man hey thanks man but
honestly because I can't see you just to
contemplate in no way I am I'm a massive
overthinker I'm a huge over there and
just sit there and do nothing bro
congratulations man honestly yeah I'm a
man that is true though but you have
action now I'm trying bro I'm trying
yeah it's not there 100 let's be real
and I get mad at him because he reminds
me of me so
but he's worse than I am well anytime
and we I've talked about this a lot but
anytime this dude even when you ask me
to do the podcast the first time I was
like
that's gonna do his part but Dave is
trying to do things for me and try to
put me on game but in my eyes I'm like
find somebody else dude
find somebody else dude do you think
you're not good enough yeah that's what
it is that's what it is thank you I
appreciate that now we're getting all
gay and sentimental dude yeah
this guy hey this guy's gonna be here to
me ever again okay can I explain it okay
okay so you're saying I've only brought
him on this podcast because this is my
therapy I had to talk to my therapist I
gotta get some gripes off your chest
okay yeah we got some [ __ ] to say and
I've been waiting a quite a while to
bring him on his podcast for quite a
while and I'll tell you this I didn't
want to bring you one because you are my
abuser
this is like 2020 right are you lying
you sexually assaulted David one time
twice how many times okay you know when
he lost accounts you know when you talk
to friends right you joke around you
make jokes there's a couple of things
that happen when he and I have
conversations we say some salacious [ __ ]
crazy things right what and so I forget
that when I talk to him that it's only a
conversation between me and Jason and
most normal people don't talk like this
we don't say these things to normal
people I've lost so many friends because
of him like I legit wrote this thing and
I and I wrote it as a joke on my
Instagram but it for real happened like
we were just joking around on Instagram
and I didn't turn off that mode and then
my friend who just got well former
friend now who just got a nose job bro
right right and I just was like all I
all I simply wrote on her post was like
nah don't do that
it wasn't that simple
[ __ ] made me go oh I gently wrote in
cursive gently
your nose is so big it looks like you
could smell trouble with that thing
right oh that's all I said oh and I was
like Singa all right I got her yeah
suddenly I go back to her page I'm
blocked and I'm like what why why am I
blocked like how many lives did this
comment get well this is what happened
so we have reconciled since and she
apologized to me she said she just was a
little sensitive about it because it got
it got a lot of likes and then a lot I
[ __ ] knew it dude it's a [ __ ]
singer bro it's a good thing a lot of
likes and the problem with that is too
is like when you make a joke online
people just start to pile on so I wrote
that nose joke somebody else wrote a
nose joke one of the funniest ones that
I read that somebody wrote was they said
like wow your friendship really took a
nosedive and I was like
and then Eric Griffin writes a comment
on my page and he just writes she could
probably blow her nose with a towel I
was like damn that one's mean that one's
me dude and listen I started something
and look after we reconciled because I
thought it was so funny I reposted it on
my page but I didn't say who she was she
blocked me again what she blocked you
twice twice oh my God what did you
recognize
no are you gonna are gonna take a
trading order on me
you have been ruining my friendships
number two this is the other thing I'm
confronting my abuser 2020 style this
man showed me his penis and I didn't
want to see it I was joking Jason we
talk we're talking right we're on we're
you know we're dming right like
something something show me your dick
then lol clearly it's a joke this video
clearly is not clear right away this
video is the weirdest thing ever he's
like in like the comedy store or some
[ __ ] he's in the back I see him I see
him with other people and if you guys
haven't been to the back of a comedy
room where Comics wait there's a
bathroom in the back I see him giggling
like this like Cloverfield style you
know like it's a documentary and then
I'm like where is this going I see him
in a bathroom he low angles in the video
his dick is out and he just starts
slapping it against his legs oh why did
you slap against her leg that's too much
it's ASMR oh you know he likes it he
likes the sound yeah
wow wow exactly it's very good I
literally
of the day and they were kneading dough
and it The Sound reminded me of your
penis
I can't make love anymore I couldn't
[ __ ] eat whenever a [ __ ] seal
claps their hands I'm like I'm done
anytime skin slaps on skin he [ __ ]
freaks out okay can I can I just I'm
gonna fix it can I explain it
you have a cadaver penis continue
what's a cadaver penis it's covered in
formaldehyde
it looks it looks like dry mouth
it was a little dark that day it was it
was bad lighting but it's not that dark
um
this is I've been trying to figure out
what it is with the penis thing
like why you have why I have a thing for
it why you like doing it I was talking
to my sister about this okay
yeah is that before your mom or well go
ahead continue though who's next okay
she was there she was there hey sister
mom's next too Mom is there a penis why
do you think I like making jokes about
it with someone yeah so after you kiss
your sister continue
I don't kiss her
um so this is the thing with the guilty
dude yeah
after you say that one time no they'll
never defend me a good bro
I'm going to jail for real I'm dead he
didn't do it
what the [ __ ]
maybe maybe not
so the reason why with the penis is uh
because of the thing is two reasons one
thing is so that I'm getting to it Nick
no I'm not doing it stay tuned
continue
okay so we're gonna look at you one of
the one of the things is
well you you [ __ ] scratching your
head right now it's not coming out it's
a thing okay okay so so one thing is
when um
I wanted to uh show that like if
everybody is vulnerable then we could
connect I know that's not everybody and
that's my second point is that even
though most people
don't are not physically outwardly and I
could respect that even though Europeans
are a little more outwardly but the
villagers whose dick and penises and the
titties is on the outside most of the
time the titties right yeah right
they're still on the outside but I feel
like that's normal like we should just
be like more naked and more like Inward
and outward and then we just go see
where's the same people people do you
think the villagers like in their loin
cloth with their dick out they just lift
it up and they start slapping against
their thighs do you think they do that
okay let me tell you something you yes
and what I just said you do this you go
against it and now I'm sad no I'm just
asking like do you think no you're right
you slap their titties around look at
this special extra this slap is that
shot but I just to me is like a bonding
experience do you feel closer with him
after you guys did that but do you know
what I mean though it's not I'm not I
don't want to force you but that's why
like I think Korean dads when they're
like hey come and scrubs back it breaks
a barrier David's blinking slow so slow
right now do you know what I mean
do you know what I mean so it's like no
sword you're not hiding a sword in your
pants I listen I've never been sexually
assaulted through a DM before I
apologize all right no it's done I have
God I have been going through extensive
therapy I literally can't hear this
sound without screaming into a pillow
wait can you really make that noise
right now
it checks out have you guys FaceTime
since oh we will never FaceTime ever
again now I'm scared I apologize there's
some there's like literally a tribe in
Africa right now yeah they're cringing
as you speak they're like we don't do
that
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what he is talking about I don't walk
around and do to other people
this [ __ ] walk around all he do
is walk around tell people I don't do
that this is this is what they're
hearing right now people in Europe are
very mad at you right now they're like
you know we don't do this all David
that's culture culture appropriation
oh yeah you got me yeah you're really
good you got the extensive therapy
that's where you got me you stupid [ __ ]
you go to therapy and also here's the
other thing I don't feel special because
you do that with other people too oh
we're good friends though for example
Patrick Riley yeah I love Pat okay who
else David Pat and my friend Dexter okay
okay I'm the real person but continue
Dexter yeah
my friend Archibald [ __ ] you dude Dexter
who's Dexter my friend airlight
cabinet you piece of [ __ ]
when's the first time you show somebody
your dick that wasn't uh nobody
I lied I lied let me think you're lying
I I think I showed um
okay on The Bachelor bachelor party
somebody else's bachelor party we win a
golf cart and we would like five and
five and I was really drunk and I showed
my dick to the public well you said five
on five
because five five people on One golf
cart the other person
yeah yeah it was a five on five I'm in
on five man yeah or ten-man orgy yeah I
show it then but it was really cold and
um it was it wasn't a good
representation it wasn't it wasn't I
just wanted to say that but let me ask
you something else too this is what I'm
also gonna ask you a lot of gripes why
but does that make sense though the
naked thing earlier you were slightly
hard why I wasn't slightly hard
that's impressive then we went from the
beginning that's what I wanted to show
you it wasn't big I know what ladies and
gentlemen are you proud of your penis no
I accept it that's cool that's a good
answer that's a good answer that's a
good answer
that's a great answer I have that
slightly bro bro
I have a slightly below average size
payment and me too man this little saw
Pat's dick and he just felt to shade
them he was like what the [ __ ] dude
apparently Pat's dong is gigantic it's
like a [ __ ] water balloon dude like
it's like a water balloon like just
relaxing and dude I've always known Pat
had a fatal is it hard or soft is what
I'm saying soft okay like it's like
flooded it's fully yelling at me and
Cherry stop yelling I didn't give him
that dick what are you talking about
right now soft he's like mad at you he's
mad at you it's like a garbage bag with
water in it
and I was really upset yeah you're
pissed and the dude his girl then was
right there too and I was like bro why
do you gotta show it like that and be so
comfortable yeah yeah I I'm not
exaggerating it's like a garbage bag
with with a lot of water in it have you
ever showed Pat your dick no dude you
guys never done we don't do that bro I
don't know you'd be showing your ass a
lot though I that was like early 20s
Nick I haven't showed myself that was
literally like a couple weeks ago [ __ ]
I don't know what you're [ __ ] talking
about okay okay okay
why are you showing your ass man because
I think it's funny when I'm walking away
and then like say we're like in a group
of friends and then we're I'm walking
ahead of the group and then like I'll
I'll pull my pants down but then pull my
shirt all the way over and then like
I'll just hike it up real quick and then
it gets laughs I think it's a fun time
and it's like harmless it's like oh but
everyone has a butt yeah every morning
no not everybody dude not everybody not
everybody but a lot of people at least
maybe half of the population yeah so
then who is Dexter is my friend he I've
known him since
whenever you say things it always sounds
like you're lying it does it does who is
Dexter person
he has a nose
he has one eyes plus another one
together two eyes yes
buy one get one free yeah I want to see
you just witness a crime and piss off a
cop the whole time what did the person
look like you guys mouth okay what else
besides about face
he breathe dog [ __ ] Miss Swan over
here
he looked like a man
you know oh yeah you're looking like a
man
dude
you don't have a [ __ ] miss swanis
dude sorry I didn't have a childhood
okay not in the states at least yeah
yeah but this one is nice she's a person
that you're gonna tell me who she is
right now this one is uh so in Mad TV
she played a so Alex Borstein which I
didn't know she wasn't Asian you know
she white she's Jewish oh More Steam oh
yeah oh right but she did a really good
impression of like an Asian nail salon
so I always assume that Al sports team
was half asian but she kind of look at
it too she kind of looks crazy she would
imitate like the Korean lady who does
her nails and that's how she developed
this lady Miss Swan but Miss Swan would
always do [ __ ] like you where every time
somebody would come in and ask her
something it's like oh who did this
I forgot that's what the bit was dude I
don't do it like that when I first saw
that on Mad TV I was crying laughing it
was so good it was so [ __ ] funny you
can't do that nowadays now she'll be
canceled immediately
what about you fool what you piece of
[ __ ] why do you talk like that hers is a
character dude [ __ ] real life yeah in
real life you don't talk like that
either yeah I I think um you'd like to
piss us off on podcasts whenever cameras
yeah because I get a little
uncomfortable yeah and also um what do
you feel what do you mean what do you
mean with the thing I feel like well
when we're not on camera we have normal
conversations like where you I'll ask
you questions
I've never had a normal conversation
with this guy dude earlier on camera
every time he says something to me it
sounds like he's trying to piss me off
like literally like I'm over in Hawaii
listen to me I'm over here in Hawaii
trying to open up a [ __ ] business
right and the way he says [ __ ] pisses me
off like ego so you do marketing right
so what do you do and I'm like wow no
I'm just direct like because I I'm
really curious of what because I would
like to learn just like the camera thing
I was like and you try to teach me stuff
and I like to learn because I'm like oh
man like these are information and
things that you could learn from a
person who does a thing that you don't
do
genuine curious don't take it personally
bro you literally just did a whole bunch
of [ __ ] nothing right now what okay I
understand what you're saying I'm trying
to learn right you talk to somebody who
knows something and then that's how you
learn don't be [ __ ] do it you talk
like a vlogger dude you know vloggers
when they're on camera they just
literally have nothing to say so they
just describe [ __ ] so guys you know this
is a pillow I rest my head on it you
know when you get sleepy right you know
when I had a pillow as a kid pillows
but I swear to God is because I like to
learn I'm not like I don't do the
vlogger voice I don't do the this
genuine how many years have you been
wait you were born in Taiwan right yeah
when did you come here
14. if you came [ __ ] late that's not
that late that's pretty late dude now
that explains a lot that's a lot of
years are in Taiwan that explains why
you're so like straightforward with like
you there's like sometimes like that
lost Nuance when you learn a new
language yeah right but did you learn
how to speak English in Taiwan yeah but
everybody learns English in Taiwan
everybody yeah because they have English
classes but you're not fluent you still
like my dad speaks English but his
accent is very thick still
um but I wanted to assimilate so I so I
did uh I try to have speak as fluently
as possible I still have an accent a
little bit but I try not to because I
wanted to be cool but the thing is uh
but yeah but I wanted to learn it for
reals yeah I wanted to learn the thing
okay so when you when you came here
right where did you learn how to speak
English like you're you think I'm this
genuine
okay I think he does I think he does
think that I'm not this one has yelled
at me twice already
I said nothing listen Okay because most
people when they learn a language right
they they kind of learn from like for
example for me when I was two I clearly
learned how to speak English from
watching TV and it was from like Mr
Rogers it was from like Sesame Street
like what was your thing
I I'm gonna tell you the truth is Rush
Hour
um one that makes I'm watching it every
single day every single day for probably
almost every single day definitely over
300 times for over a year what's your
favorite that explains a lot so because
we were in the car right one time we
were in the car and I touched the radio
Jason
he sounds like Chris Tucker bro that's
that's where that's what it is you sound
like yeah sometimes you sound like Money
Talks Chris Tucker sometimes it comes
out you always wanted to go to square
modern
oh my God
no you're not gonna [ __ ] disrespect
me
I
don't have anything right now
maybe a little rush hour though why not
I really liked it because it was so
funny and I loved both of the characters
I really loved both of the characters
and also uh
uh my I don't know what this got
anything to do with it but my roommate
was black
and I was I really liked just he's so
cute he's like yeah he's like why do you
keep following me everywhere okay so I
watched this movie called
and I need you to dance with me
dance with me yeah he just plays War all
the time
wow
yeah yeah what did you learn that
twisting tiger you want camel's hump
okay what's up
I'm talking about the trouble
so that's why you stopped like Jackie
Chan huh
no sometimes I feel like I'm like uh
different characters when when I express
things yeah like like what like what are
some like sometimes I'll have like a
urban character like a black accent okay
I want you to imitate a black person no
I'm not gonna do that okay well all
right let's let's do it like what's the
situation when you would use that accent
let's hear it I don't know like when I'm
um hanging around a bunch of black
people no never Let's Hear This Racist
rendition
especially if there's black people I
always do the opposite I always try to
be as proper English as possible
okay let's try this out what's up my
brothers how are y'all today a bunch of
job turkeys
seventies we'll walk around with a half
a little pistachios what's up baby what
y'all young is about to get into today
y'all better than that now that's just
sexy bro walking around here sagging
your pants y'all better than that we
came up
a piece of cardboard start shooting dice
against it who's trying to shoot some
dice
so you could switch the opposite way
yeah I do the opposite I do the opposite
hello young gentlemen yeah because I
want to respect it yeah I want to
respect the man and I I'm more conscious
of like I just want to try to be myself
uh when there's an African-American man
um yeah I try to yeah I I don't try to
um yeah do it
the uh The Voice okay that's it Nick is
a young black American man and I want
you to speak to him
his brain by David so is brought to you
by better help online therapy my friends
unfortunately life doesn't come with the
user manual so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel a little stuck
that's how I feel sometimes but after I
speak to my therapist on better help uh
help helps me out a lot
um maybe it sounds like I'm saying this
too much but I really really do enjoy
better help online therapy and you know
what I gotta tell you your boy doesn't
know everything of course as you've seen
on this podcast but the crazy thing is
is that sometimes when I feel like I'm
crazy I talk to my therapist and you
know he helps me kind of just navigate
the [ __ ] in my head like it's life is
hard man and when you feel like you have
nowhere to go and you need somebody to
talk to that's people outside of maybe
your wife your girlfriend your boyfriend
or whoever that you're with or even your
closest friends your therapist can
really really help you out and if you
haven't tried therapy try better help
because honestly you get to learn a lot
of coping skills um self-empowerment and
if you have like empowerment empowerment
and if you're dealing with trauma on
honestly therapy is the best so just you
know give it a go you have nothing to
lose as the world's largest therapy
service better help has Match 3 million
people with professionally licensed
embedded therapists online and it's
super affordable all you have to do is
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with the therapist that things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime and it couldn't be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more save 10 off your
first month at betterhealth.com genius
that's better help
help.com genius
hello Jason my name is Jason how are you
today I don't talk to black people
gets worse
yeah
not that it gets worse and worse every
time you speak dude and I don't
understand how you [ __ ] do it I
apologize I apologize I already
apologize
I apologize
it was a joke that's a good joke I'm
Jason I'm scared
he just locks his car door click
I'm scared I'll be so scared oh my God
please don't touch my radio
I like the Beach Boys because I feel
like if you're not authentic to anybody
they sense it yeah they can smell that
[ __ ] out yeah for sure yeah if you're
not attending when you try to yeah it's
weird though I think for 100 everybody
code switches though like I I it's it's
very [ __ ] common I think it's weird
when people code switch and it's hyper
apparent like for example like I've I've
definitely seen like a couple of people
who are like in the YouTube world like
they'll I so there was this girl
we don't kick it anymore
got a little weird but either way every
time she was around like any [ __ ]
black dude black girl black woman or
whatever it was literally the [ __ ]
worst rendition of like how media
portrays black Americans right it's
offensive and it was so hard to watch
and like her husband I would always look
at her husband he was just being like
oh my God right legit because she does
music a lot of like the music you know
she's very talented and
the music that she creates a lot of
producers are black I [ __ ] you [ __ ]
not she'll be talking to somebody else
right like oh how are you how you doing
and one one black person walks by and
then I said girl I was like you ain't
gonna do this and I'm like
okay I'm like Jesus crushed yeah and I'm
sitting here just cringing so [ __ ]
hard and by the way too and I feel like
the people around her being very kind
but you could tell that it's kind of
like okay laughing they're uncomfortable
it's just shoot on their face [ __ ]
uncomfortable and I remember one time
where
we were all drunk and I and I was
looking at her I'm like why do you do
that
right and then she got really up she
goes you're not the only person that
grew up with black people David and I'm
like that's not what I was saying I'm
saying like you code switch super
[ __ ] hard and it's very uncomfortable
she goes and this is the most awkward
thing that she did she gets her phone
she goes into her Facebook right and
then she shows her black friends all of
her black friends on Facebook and it's
it's a it's a high school it's a high
school picture of her on like the stomp
team
and I'm like this is so [ __ ] awkward
right now I can't stand this because
like I know black people too I was like
that inadvertently just sounds racist to
me I don't know why and that moment has
burned in my head because
I think like certain people too they
want to be accepted so [ __ ] hard that
they don't know how to be comfortable in
their own [ __ ] skin because I code
switch a lot too like I code switch in
the sense of like if if there's a white
person around me I definitely try to
like you know hey how's it going like no
I wired it up a little bit well for like
last night
well it works I think sometimes it's not
that it's necessary I just feel like
it's probably beneficial to code switch
um for work
because then if you do a certain type of
thing they may not accept you
um or like respect you if you don't uh
try to be as proper as possible let me
ask you guys this this is a very
interesting thing I was thinking about
so for you two right because now you
guys have a little bit of notoriety you
know people know who you are people have
asked you for pictures and stuff now huh
it's weird it's really weird
can I touch your ear
[ __ ] I haven't gotten that yet yeah
that's a little while they're gonna do
it they get a little drunk they'll do it
so have you guys have ever experienced
um like relationships in your past
before you started getting like
notoriety and doing what you're doing
where these people hate you suddenly out
of nowhere have you experienced that yet
ah not that I know of I feel you like
you I've always had the same solid group
of friends yeah so you're pretty fine
with that what about you you Gypsy
[ __ ] Gypsy dude well I gotta be a
gypsy because you travel around so much
so like has anybody ever duh yeah idiot
and you sell trinkets on the road and
you live in a caravan yeah can I wear
tie-dye shirts
uh I don't but I honestly my friends are
I don't have that many friends and I
have some friends and I really love them
and um
so I don't really experience that but
people are definitely different though
like if you have anything not not even
whatever the thing is even just a small
success people talk to you differently
and especially in uh I think anywhere
any entertainment or even just in any
business world if you have like some
sort of success people talk a little bit
differently to you and you the the
switch is so obvious
like before I would never get
places that would never book me and they
wouldn't talk to me even smile
um it would just spit in your mouth when
you walk by almost hi open up
yeah
my bad I thought you were an ashtray
you just take their cigarette put it out
in your mouth yeah here's your pay for
the day yeah but yeah this really is
really obvious that some not all but um
yeah it's obvious when
um yeah but to me it's crazy though
because it's not even like suddenly
you're doing anything different yeah
it's not doing anything different and
I'm not like a different person and also
I really don't feel like it's I'm not
like
uh because to me I have nothing is the
thing I always feel that way but you're
talking about specifically where you see
it the most is when like Club promoters
Club promoters because they're like oh
this thing could fill up a room yeah
fill up a room and they have something
to make money yeah yeah but yeah because
of that yeah but um yeah how does that
make you feel does that make you feel
used no but I just feel some type of way
I need a beat yeah how does that make
you feel though like for real uh but I
always feel but I knew that it was
always going to be like that yeah but
this switch is just so apparent that I'm
just like oh yeah of course yeah but
still weird are they like a lot more
buddy buddy of course oh of course yeah
I was like hey Jason how you doing man
yeah hey killing it like the [ __ ] bro
yeah you literally put a cigarette out
in my eye yesterday I have an eye patch
on today I can't see you have a story
that you told us about that one time you
were doing a show and dude don't touch
me man there's no way to connect uh you
can connect with me you're doing a show
and they for the picture that they use
they used music never sleeps Jason
Chan's show but it wasn't I swear the
culture was so big
David
the size of the door
it was the size of the door you know
what's so [ __ ] funny though it's like
that's how you go to jumbi matcha and
just my face on the [ __ ] thing it's
like this is not me so what the [ __ ] you
mean that is hilarious dude oh well at
least both of you guys are Taiwanese and
you guys kind of have the same name you
know he's five foot one yeah yeah yeah
no yeah but uh but it's cool though I
just try to have a good time man yeah
and I don't ever want to hear you
complain about a poster being [ __ ]
nowhere dude which I haven't even I've
already talked about on the podcast
where you [ __ ] ambushed me at
Carvel's I will never ever forgive you
for that dude stand up yes and I oh I
told you I have crazy anxiety I know but
I always forget that seriously I always
forget that seriously how could you
forget yeah I always forget because she
watches that maybe hide it so of course
our watch is that was it pretty good it
was good he's too popular it was good
and we ate it on stage
it was like I it it literally felt like
you didn't leave the stage
but the said I know it was a workout
because it was a workout I'm like that
looks like somebody that just like
working [ __ ] out as well I literally had
no material the return of David So to
the store I knew it was natural that
when when he did it I wasn't like oh man
this he's like wow I wasn't like that I
was just like yeah me and Pat were both
in the back like oh yeah of course
yeah like why was he tripping because
you're just like this like on the pad or
anywhere else I want to sock you in your
chest so bad you're such an Asian parent
this will just text me and be like when
are you gonna [ __ ] do stand them
you're gonna just be a loser your whole
life I don't say that because he does do
I have to [ __ ] I take this life I say
this life
I didn't say your whole life hurry up
and [ __ ] do it I told you I'll do it
because it'll be a good time dude you're
not you jumping Macho it's just [ __ ]
powder in the water dude and what's his
name
don't you disrespect my jewelry matcha
like that dude all right it's more than
just it was it was it's a 100 year old
Farm it's stone ground it's so delicious
it's earthy and smooth I'm so busy I
gotta do marketing the powder and the
water all right I gotta Stir It how come
it looks like you're milking a cow you
[ __ ] idiot
this is where a macho come from and buff
for no reason yeah
muscles and you do nothing but those are
saying just come and do it man it'll be
a good time is the thing I told you next
year I promise you let me tell you
something
next year is in two months you keep on
saying next year is like five years away
yeah okay [ __ ] guy okay
[Laughter]
I'm working on some things okay okay and
it's gonna happen it's gonna be the
genius brain I'm gonna host it and then
you now
I wanted to bring you up
you'll be so funny I wanted to be a host
I like hosting okay all right so I will
host this whole Comedy Tour it'll be you
it'll be Pat it'll be Chris and then you
guys have to [ __ ] kill it because if
you don't it's my name you pieces of
[ __ ]
no pressure but dude that's gonna be
safely say he he likes the host because
um he doesn't want to headline it
because he's being a little [ __ ] oh see
that doesn't work on me I saw you got
beat up in real life so
if you're headlining
if you're a headliner uh 45 to an hour I
like to do 55 55 yeah right I can't I've
only done like one time where I went
like 45 minutes and it's it's long it's
really long it's really long but if you
keep doing it it's fun though is the
thing and especially people
I um know you is the thing have you
found a special yet
um
no
I want to I would like to yeah
it's a very simple question have you
tried a special ed oh God Jesus Christ
it was a very troubling noise
Chris Tucker line yeah oh [ __ ]
I I want to is the thing yeah but um I
think I'm also
I'm also insecure like I'm like man I
wanted to be so good and because you're
always evolving and growing and
sometimes like if I in like six months I
look back I'm like no I could have done
that better but I have to get over but
also I don't want to
because I work on it so hard I spend so
much time on it and now I have this
mediocre after I talk about this when
all other Comics too like after nine
years 10 years of working on it and now
it's mediocre and now if I put it out
and nobody watches it that will make me
a little bit sad you think nobody would
watch it people will watch it you know I
don't know like nobody knows like some
because people have specials are out on
platforms and it doesn't do well and
that hurts and now you got to do a next
hour but I'm always working on
um new things but dude I've literally
offered I mean this this is this is what
it is like there's a lot of people that
I you know try to push forward right A
lot of people are full of [ __ ] though
there's a lot of people who are Comics
who I genuinely believe like they kind
of like the anonymity because the
anonymity allows you to kind of do what
you want without being without the fear
of failing right and I've and I've
talked to like other Comics too have
been doing it for a very long time I was
like listen I'll use my platform like
I'll take your special I'll put it on my
thing I'll give you all of the ad
revenue from it right if you just need
eyes right because if it's something
like that we'll just put it on my
channel it'll be all your credit I'll
give you all the ad revenue for that
specific video wow no problem and
literally two people haven't called me
on that and it's like you said you were
ready yeah so if you want if you just
want eyes on it alone we'll put it on my
channel and then
I'll produce the whole [ __ ] thing for
you that's really nice
you don't have to do that but that's
really nice that you have enough you
need a personal assistant
but you know what also this is a deeper
dive I don't know how long this and I'm
getting a little nervous because maybe
it's towards the end of the thing it
might be too long it would be a pot but
um this is another thing is that
just share your feelings bro yeah
so um but this is another thing is
another thing is like uh
uh I forgot another thing
hello anybody home
absolutely what it's like when he talks
this is the person in his head going
anybody home
talk like Andre the [ __ ] giant [ __ ] I
just started but they want the peanut
anybody else
another thing is this is that
um sometimes on crowds it's not because
I I listen to your podcast with the
Jesus and with other Comics as well and
some people's like because you're so
nice to your friends or people who you
appreciate and sometimes you're like oh
Jason's so funny but it's like
it's so subjective and yeah you know
this like comedy subjective and
sometimes I'm like
because if I for example if I perform in
front of a crowd that is over 50 years
old I'm not gonna get the same reaction
if I perform in front of an Asian
American crowd if I Crush in an American
crowd and then I bomb like you could go
like I could adjust my style to better
fit a 50 and above crowd but those
material and the way I perform is going
to be very different than how I would
want to perform
um as myself in front of the people who
know who I am and accept me does that
make sense oh 100 but that's why when
when we
I'll shoot it for you like when we shoot
the special you're gonna do it like five
six times and then we're gonna cut from
five six shows like when you do these
standard specials it's not from one show
yeah yeah yeah
it's literally four or five shows in the
same place yeah different plan and they
get the right laughs in the right crowd
yeah and at the same time too because
it's like a performance aspect of you
doing it like that
it's going to be a different vibe and
feel what I figured out too especially
watching like like Kevin Hart right when
I watch Kevin Hart on TV he's not that
funny but I've been to that same set
where I watched him live so I was like
yeah yeah right A lot of the stuff
doesn't really translate some people's
comedy they don't translate well on
screen you're right and it kind of sucks
and Kevin Hart happens to be one of
those people I've literally seen Kevin
Hart perform live three times that's how
funny I think that he is yeah right and
I saw those that same special for some
reason on TV it doesn't translate but
also of venue matters too oh yeah 100
yeah venue and then how they edit it
like um because sometimes because the
audio if you just have mic One mic for
the crowd it sounds a little flat but
then if you mic like if you have 15 mics
for the crowd and then layer it together
but not loud but just it if it feels
like more you're in the room listen I've
seen I'm not even sure people remember
this but uh
Dave Chappelle did the uh Mark Twain
award thing right yeah did you guys see
the original cut that was on PBS no so I
saw the original cut that was on PBS it
is vastly different than the one it
sounds like he bombed or what so because
there's no laughter right there was no
laughing yeah so they added laugh tracks
and specifically one comment but do you
think laugh tracks or was it just from
the room uh sometimes I'll add lashes
for the for the one for the one with uh
the Mark Twain award yeah for uh Dave
Chappelle the comic that went up it
bombed yeah was Tiffany haddish
so Tiffany haddish in the PBS one right
which if everybody gets a hold of this
[ __ ] I remember this because I was dying
watching her mom she was making these
jokes and like specifically she was you
could tell she was very nervous
um and watching her perform and I didn't
think the jokes were funny listen
Tiffany I think she's hilarious like
I've seen her on like movies and stuff
she cracks me the [ __ ] up but
specifically that performance she did
this joke she goes yeah I met Dave
Chappelle and I met him he was like I'm
Dave Chappelle [ __ ] and then she did
that joke Dead Silence yeah and then she
continued maybe three more jokes Dead
Silence but Netflix one they added a
laugh track wait wait Netflix but same
venue and same venue same everything and
they started cutting videos of like Dave
Chappelle laughing in the PBS one it was
Jester on stage and [ __ ] dead bro you
know what's crazy because you you were
saying this they added the thing um
recently we discovered a comic I'm not
gonna say his name but he performs in
his living room okay and he he makes the
background looks like he's on stage bro
the the last the way the last the laughs
that he picks for each punch line is so
good it literally looks like when you
when I watch it I go oh yeah he's he's
just comic but he doesn't he never
performed on a stage until like more
recent but the clips go viral and people
like oh my God he's so funny so now he
sells tickets too but then he's not
doing a long time he does like 10 15
minutes at the end and he puts like
seven Comics up before but that's so
crazy that the technology and because
the laughs you can't if you add like a
weird laugh
in like a a small punch line then it
sounds weird but he's so meticulous with
it and then the way you react to laughs
as well he's so good but that takes a
little bit of like craziness oh 100
because if you perform a [ __ ] living
room you're like yeah you guys are so
crazy you guys so good you might as well
just [ __ ] performance like he's doing
crowd work to a teddy bear yeah
yeah a little tea party for like yeah 50
stuffed animals that's what I'm saying
it but that's a crazy price people the
things that people can do that's crazy
right the cool thing about comedy is
though is like he can go ahead and do
these shows as much as he wants yeah
that's one thing you can't cheat you
can't cheat like yeah right so when he
has to do that 30 minute set or when he
has to when somebody comes up like hey
yo here's money yeah like we're gonna
pay you this big amount let's let's sell
out of [ __ ] Stadium yeah and he goes
out and then he has to do an hour set
and it's the worst thing ever yeah he's
going to tank he's going to get that one
check and he's gonna disappear yeah it's
just that's just how he can't treat it
that's what I like about comedy though
it's so honest either you're funny or
you're [ __ ] not right like you could
we could knock like you know we talk
about Brendan Shaw ball he wants but he
has a fan base for a reason he's making
somebody [ __ ] laugh right not me but
he's making no that wasn't a knock that
was that other that was just honest I
know it's not a knock but it's just it's
just funny the way you [ __ ] set it up
yeah you're a comedian dude yeah so you
know
not me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're a piece of [ __ ] dude you're a
piece of [ __ ]
we're gonna ask you next don't [ __ ]
you you you [ __ ] wait dude I
deflected you know he's he's worked his
credit the thing is he's working his
material to the point where the people
who follow him they like him they
[ __ ] find him funny and comedy is
very very subjective somebody like that
though that's faking the laughs they
don't even know when the good pocket is
they don't even know how to form their
material yeah and you can't fight that
you just have to like even when we when
I went up to harvest like The First
beginning was so hard because I couldn't
feel it out and it took a bit a little
bit a little bit I was like okay I'm
feeling it out a little bit now right
but you how would I have done that to
teddy bears yeah yeah yeah yeah I would
have performed it like how I would have
performed and I wouldn't even know if
it's funny yeah yeah I just wouldn't
yeah you know you sometimes like in your
head when you think things are so
[ __ ] hilarious you perform in a bombs
you're like oh I'm not that funny let me
take that joke out how do you do that
when there's nobody there and like when
to add the laughs right exactly it's
just terrible there's so many times
where I thought something was funny and
I was like this is going to get them and
then literally I just go home and I cry
but you know what though maybe another
crowd would like it do you know what I
mean yeah that's the thing that's what I
was saying about like the that's why
sometimes I'm like
there's a median like you have to choose
I think you have to choose like do you
want to make everybody laugh all the
time and just be all very well-rounded
comic like a comedian you or do you want
to say the things in your heart and
accept that sometimes you bomb because
of that those aren't the crowd that
really appreciate you like I like that
one like I think before I was the other
way around yeah but the problem with
that is that I think there's a skill in
it right there's a skill there's a skill
in learning how to like look at the
crowd and say ages 40 30 for 2020 I
gotta mold this joke this way it'll hit
right I think the problem with that
though is that it's very exhausting like
it's so it it tires you out right
because you're not really focusing on
your joke now you're you're bet you're
changing the joke for these other people
right that's why like somebody I
appreciate somebody like uh Joe Coy like
Joe Coy has pretty much done the same
jokes for the past like 10 years just a
different flip of it right but Joko is
not trying to appeal to the everyday
person he's appealing to the Filipino
crowd yeah his if you've ever ever been
to a Filipino who the [ __ ] is this huh
[ __ ] guy bro on his own podcast I
can't believe it very disrespectful to
him I was saying something profound
the Joker
that's my go-to nervous stick now
but like when you when you have like
when you're crafting jokes and you're
figuring out like okay these are my
bangers when you test them out across
different crowds in different cities or
whatever do you have jokes that you like
oh these always yeah but you could
totally you know why they hit because
it's so more like broad more generic or
more like relatable and the jokes are so
simple that you're like there's no
Nuance to get there's no do you ever
have the temptation to chase that like
of course in the beginning yeah in the
beginning I did that I I I was like I
just want to be the funniest on the
lineup it doesn't matter what I said
yeah even though if I'm making fun of
myself my Heritage I don't know why I
say heritage that's fine what's wrong
with that my cabin Scrolls
[Laughter]
this is the thing if you chase that and
then you bomb you your life now you're
back nothing but then at least like if
you say something in your heart but
there's a Double H though because if you
say something in your heart and then you
bomb at least you're like well I said
what I wanted to say but then I always
tell myself I'm like well are you just
making an excuse that you're saying what
you want but then you're not funny are
you not funny because of that but then
so sometimes I'm like oh you have to if
you want to sharpen it you're like no it
doesn't matter you got to tell yourself
it doesn't matter this is not your crowd
but get them yeah you just one of the
funniest today yeah be the funniest
right now so like say you have a premise
that you feel like [ __ ] myself okay
that's fine too but if you have a
premise that you like okay this is what
I want to say this is what I wanna put
out to the crowd do you ever chase that
like okay no it bombed but I could
rework this to try to make it funny or
no that's the thing I that's the best
thing to do but the thing is
um I feel like everybody has a style and
they go well this is how I say things
but also
stage time is so scarce when a person
like myself it's not at the level where
you could go up wherever you want and
also there's a pressure of like people
watching you there's a pressure of like
would I get booked back and also you
only have 10 15 minutes so if you have
10 15 minutes I could either rework this
joke or try new things or uh tighten up
other jokes so then you have to choose
like yeah your bangers and then you
still have to get them so it's like it's
you try to prioritize every time you go
up like do I want to rework the jokes
today what is my goal today and then you
go oh today I just want to kill no
matter what then then you have to hit
that goal but then you never feel good
the only time you feel good is if you
have an hour and you go I have five new
jokes I don't want to do and I want to
do a little bit of crowd work and I want
to do the old jokes and I want the whole
set to be good and I want the ending for
people to love me and have a really
great show and all of them have to hit
and that never happens they're either
like your crowd work was garbage or your
new joke didn't work or your old jokes
it wasn't hitting like you want to or
you [ __ ] up a thing or whatever
there's always a thing that you're like
oh I didn't hit this thing so I'm never
you're never happy yeah when you have a
really good set is always like an
accident
um yeah it's always like what the [ __ ]
happened you got to figure it out why
you got so many laughs or something yeah
or like the crowd's too good you never
you feel good you're like oh my God that
was a fun time but you're never like
that crowd would have laughed at
anything yeah who cares I'm useless yeah
yeah I swear to God that's how most
Comics feel
or or a lot of them there's definitely
like those weird moments too where I
look back in I think when you first
started doing stand-up because you know
I started when I was like 16 right it's
it's like you you try so hard to make
everybody laugh at every given [ __ ]
second right that you don't ever allow
yourself to breathe or think yeah so and
I remember like this moment where I was
like a little like disgusted with myself
was when I stopped doing this and this
was later on right where I was like
anytime something bad would happen I saw
a crowd that was white I knew if I did
like any type of Asian accent they were
gonna laugh and I always went to that
[ __ ] and then I I remember I sat down
one day and I was like I'm not doing
this anymore I'm like because if they
don't find me funny and they they're
they're not laughing at the joke They're
laughing at my people yeah and I just
felt really gross I did that too you
know and I hated that [ __ ] and that was
like one of those moments where I
started watching like
people like George Carlin Chappelle and
I'm like George Carlin that's a really
deep cut but sorry to interrupt device
before I say okay George Carlin if you
listen to his things it's I mean I was
talking to my sister about it that I
kissed one time
more than once for sure what it was let
me tell you about George Carlin
can I share something with you
okay okay the thing is like he doesn't
crush it but he's saying some [ __ ] that
people even remember and recall till
today yeah yeah I mean because he's
saying in his heart and there's no way
George Carlin will crush her crowd
harder than some of the comics that we
like today but he still is funny you
can't take away his funny story I just
want to say that he's saying stuff
that's important to him right and like
he Paces himself really well I think
that's what I like about Dave Chappelle
Dave Chappelle doesn't sound like he's
doing stand-up right he sounds like he's
just telling a [ __ ] story and you're
cracking the [ __ ] up yes I think that's
what I also liked about like I watched
Shane Gillis is special right it's
really funny
yeah and that I think that is the key
that makes you a great stand-up comic
and I'm like how do I get that it's so
seamless yeah how do I become so
effortlessly funny where I'm not making
jokes I'm funny yeah I could I could
make anything [ __ ] yeah but you are
like that though honestly not on stage
two Nick two you both are like
I'm a personal trainer no you gotta
choke people out you're busy choking
people out
I'm too busy getting choked you do busy
choking people out too busy in my foot
locked but you're so funny man I think
both of you have that but like when I
watch Shane girls and stuff right I was
like people tell me you're so funny and
I watch it dude there was a point I was
crying laughing yeah I was like holy
[ __ ] I haven't laughed that hard in this
special
second dude like when I watch Chappelle
especially I laughed like that and I saw
Shane I was like oh this guy's like the
one yeah hella good yeah dude like
despite all that other stuff that people
didn't like about his podcast [ __ ] or
whatever whatever people make mistakes
it's not like he's out there like going
like no I deserve to say that [ __ ] yeah
that shit's over bro whatever you're a
comic go be funny right you could be mad
at somebody and they could just not do
it again and I'm fine you just got yeah
his attention wasn't no at the time he's
just trying to be funny you know the
intention yeah I think it was and if you
look back into it was his buddy that was
way worse than him yeah I think Shane
was just kind of like bouncing off him
another guy was a little weird but like
when I saw his stand-up and I at first I
went to watch his standard because I
wanted to see his sketches and his
sketches were cracking
so good you're the only Fan's Dad yeah
[ __ ] hilarious they're so [ __ ]
funny and I was like dude this guy's
standing has to be good yeah saw that
[ __ ] I [ __ ] cried well even like the
sketches like you haven't even seen
sketches like that in a really long time
where it's like it ends perfectly the
premise is easy like you pick it up and
it's really funny and then even his
stand up like he kind of reminds me of
like like a Louis CK style because like
when Louie's up there he just sounds
like he's just talking and kind of like
shooting the [ __ ] with everybody but
then he he hits you with a punch line
you're like holy [ __ ] yeah dude that
[ __ ] was cracking me the [ __ ] up and he
put that [ __ ] like and then you know you
have somebody like um like Andrew
Schultz Andrew Schultz was like he's
just having fun yeah right he just looks
like he's having the time of his [ __ ]
life I feel like when you're up there I
feel like the same thing yeah I feel
like now I try to do I mean I always try
to do that but you know you have bad
days of course of course of course but
that's the thing too like you that
nobody ever talks about this besides you
know some big comics when I hear them
they're like dude I [ __ ] went up and
I'm talking about big Comics right like
they have a gajillion special was like I
want I get any laughs I'm like damn how
do they deal with it yeah because people
have an expectation of them being so
funny yeah dude I tried some new [ __ ]
the other day 15 minutes got a single
lap I'm like damn how did they deal with
that well I don't think they care
because honestly I I care now sorry no
no go ahead I was gonna say something
something small but I was just gonna say
like I think for those guys at the
highest level it's like they do It For
the Love of the Game probably right like
those guys are doing it because it's
like like oh I love this [ __ ] yeah like
something in any industry like the guys
that make it to the top is because they
love that craft more than anything so I
feel like for those guys I think if
you're not your heart's not really in
stand-up comedian you're just in
stand-up comedy you're there just to
kind of get attention and all that [ __ ]
you're probably not going to make it
that far the guys that like hang to the
very top stand-up comedy you say
stand-up comedian comedian you fixed it
but I just wanted to point out oh thank
you you made a mistake you've ruined my
creative error I'm sorry hey I won't do
it again I'm sorry I won't touch your
[ __ ] radio there you go
the fish
what the [ __ ] were you gonna say that
uh I confess the fish distract baby I
did I forget do you were saying the you
what you were saying no it doesn't oh
the the thing of
um how's the highest level guys at the
highest level but I feel like they also
do it because like sometimes I don't
even not that I don't care to bomb but
your goal is not to you're like [ __ ] it
if I bomb because I just want to fix
this joke I don't give a [ __ ] about the
the famous box they don't care about a
300 people crowded doing Arenas so
they're like I don't give a [ __ ] if I
bomb here that's why Chris Rock just
reads his [ __ ] he's famous to do that
because they're like he's just like oh I
just need to know if this works so
there's no like that's what I was trying
to explain to you that you shouldn't
care because usually trying to fix a
joke so that when you take that into
your crowd now it's ready now you should
care okay but listen I didn't have any
jokes you don't need it you piece of
[ __ ] you don't need it you set him up
bro all you could have said was like
[Laughter]
the famous blooper where he couldn't say
Madison Square Garden he goes I always
want to go to Square Mall
it's funny every time dude anytime you
say it
is so good
I don't even know about it you [ __ ]
liar dude don't code switch on me is
that third or second second no I saw the
third I really have a glimpse of it I
had a glimpse of it I've never heard
somebody say I've watched something 300
times but you don't remember anyone is
that number one it doesn't matter how
many times you watch two and three then
um probably
like 20 times that's a lot dude 20 is a
lot of anything I swear I was two three
like I've watched White Chicks probably
like a hundred times watch the other day
still holds up so [ __ ] so funny dude
it still holds up I love it I am who
[ __ ]
[Applause]
Arnold schwarzenegro hilarious really
good really good come on dude you said
his last name
okay I never I never I never heard
somebody say it like that this guy's
never seen white chicks you got a lot of
White Chicks I do watch White Chicks
though I do okay I didn't know I don't
remember that line is the thing I just
remembered the seafood platter thing
this even when they were eating and then
she's like keep eating like a quiche
yeah and he goes back to the house it
does really funny to me
and it's just like of uh when you talk
it sounds like a kid describing his day
that's what it is today is nice it's
like what did you do today Jeremy okay
today I woke up I had a twine and then I
thought this and then I thought this and
I made a dragon
look at the girl and I was like hi I'm a
boy
another shirt that's the name of your
special hi I'm a boy
I am a boy
Dylan's not that funny man
yeah he's had right now
and then I wake up I had a chocolate box
perfectly that's very good he captures
everybody very well yeah well guys that
wrapsed this episode of the cheese break
podcast Jason where can they find you
please find me at Jason Cheney j-a-s-o-n
like the Power Ranger
and Chinese c-h-e-n-y and um not the
cross side five foot one not the cross
side Stinger he looks like you wanna see
that you train him I don't think so God
one of his eyes is lazy one stairs at
you everyone stares his nose
I wasn't expecting that I'd be looking
in my eyes all the time and he don't
he's not that cross-eyed I'll check
again check out I'll get back to you
trust me he's look there the one goes
off he can't hands though and hey dude
you got tele T-Rex hands they ain't go
anywhere dude
okay Jason Jason Cheney c-h-e-n-e-y your
podcast plug it please d-h-e-n-y podcast
is uh before you die with me Jason
Cheney thank you so much David
so for having me on the Pod and Nick it
was uh really nice to see you on the
podcast I always like hanging out with
you Jason even though you say you don't
want to hang out with us I always enjoy
hanging out with you me too it's just
really far
okay you're gonna plug your thing plug
your [ __ ] idiot you uh see this is what
I'm talking we just talked about this we
literally just talked about this I'm
trying to promote this guy he goes uh my
name is Nick I guess you could find me
somewhere
dude I'm here all the time whatever Nick
the ear you guys know yeah but this nude
listeners mte training.com there you go
to my website go to my website he is a
if you need coaching hit me up I guess
coaching we're talking about Jujitsu
we're talking about boxing he actually
was an amateur fighter he's a brown belt
and Jiu Jitsu also too he has a degree
in kinesiology the man is a personal
trainer he can get you right hit him up
he'll be square that's how you plug
things that's how you [ __ ] play I'm
gonna get better at that you know what
I'm gonna get better at that I apologize
10 years [ __ ] later you know
should I just press this button right
here and then there's Christ Jesus point
every Sunday's at 12 p.m I'll see you
all next time